lui c'est lowen seagrave son nom ne vous
dit peut-être pas grand-chose mais il
pèse lourd dans le monde de l'athlétisme
international
il a entraîné les plus grands justin
gatlin ou encore la chine mairie des
champions olympiques de grandes
pointures de la discipline
et si aujourd'hui il est en martinique
depuis une semaine c'est parce qu'il
entraîne durant un stage spécial
quelques athlètes martiniquais à la
demande du racing club de martinique
beaucoup de technique c'est à dire de
position de bras ou encore des pieds où
on peut optimiser le plus la vélocité ma
vitesse améliorer les performances de
ceux qui visent le haut niveau c'est
l'objectif de ces sessions
d'entraînement dans différentes
disciplines saut est et sprint se savent
nous permet tout simplement de finaliser
ce cycle et pour pouvoir rentrer nos
unes dans une période de compétition
très intense et tout ça c'est toutes les
petites choses qu'il faut finaliser et
qui pourront pouvoir me faire perdre des
secondes des centièmes très précieuse
pour cette année 2009
l'échéance a préparé les carifta games
un événement sportif caribéen
véritable tremplin pour des podiums à
l'international est évident que ces deux
là c'est de la mutualisation et c'est
ici d'un entraînement avec d'autres
d'autres coaches internationaux qu'on
arrivera à et galilée jamaïcaine et
trinidad j'ai la particularité de leur
m6 grève c'est de filmer toutes les
performances des athlètes durant
l'entraînement de façon à pouvoir bien
débriefé les athlètes réagissent
beaucoup mieux à l'image ils apprennent
bien plus rapidement de cette façon 80%
du travail réalisé par rapport à sion je
capture le moment j'utilise également un
logiciel pour des ralentis et autres
effets pour mieux découper les
mouvements et des drifts
dix licenciés du racing club
cinq athlètes deux clubs différents et
deux invités guadeloupéens ont pu suivre
pendant six jours les précieux conseils
de l'oms